Скадовськ — дуже цікаве місто,
з дуже таким курортним акцентом.
Ти розумієш, що люди тут відпочивають.
Місто має інший ритм.
Повітря насичене киснем,
і всі ходять просто  відпочивають.
Так, переймаються своїми проблемами,
так само, як ми бачимо ті проблеми по телевізору.
Але є дуже багато класних людей,
які можуть зробити це місто набагато кращим.
Я місцевий активіст, так само я фрілансер,
так само я вчитель інформатики у школі.
Я голова громадської організації
«Молоді Ініціативні».
Це моя основна діяльність
як активіста місцевого.
Львович, вітаю!
Нічого не змінюється, так.
Так, так, у Єгорова.
О 19.30 юшка і кіно.
Ага, щось потрібно,
когось запрошувати ще, чи ні?
Посуд.
Супер, так, ну і ложки, і тарілки.
Ага, добре, це скільки там? 250, так?
Гаразд, добре, дякую, до вечора.
Прожив я у Скадовську все життя.
Навіть якщо я там десь працював,
від'їжджав на навчання.
Все одно я, як будь-яка людина, яка народилася на морі —
вона не може влітку не повернутися сюди.
Мені було цікаво повернутися
у Скадовськ, я повернувся 2014-го року.
Були складні часи в Києві.
І я зрозумів, що я хочу
трохи цивілізації і тут.
Людину робить її оточення.
Звичайно, познайомився з гарними людьми.
Місцевими, знову ж таки,
цікавими активістами.
Громадська організація «Молоді Ініціативні»
взагалі для мене була відкриттям.
Тому що я ніколи не думав,
що у Скадовську є якісь такі ініціативи,
які завершені, і вони вже працюють
та мають якусь структуру.
Є дуже багато людей, які зараз
дізнаються про цю організацію.
І кажуть: «Вау, клас, ми хочемо до вас доєднатися,
чим ми можемо бути корисні і як це зробити?».
Давайте ложками!
Слава Україні! Героям слава!
Ми там казан робимо
і хочемо ще ватру зробити.
Маленьку ватру.
Маленьку ватру там,
де ми будемо варити казан.
Вогнище невеличке.
Давайте тут.
Ви що, підпалити Скадовськ хочете?
Гарну ватру.
Тож буде чай варений —
візьмеш там декілька кавунів.
З 2011-го року у нас найголовнішим
проєктом був фестиваль «Битва за море».
Це фестиваль, під який і
створювалася ця громадська організація.
Від початку фінансування
жодного не було в принципі.
Ми отримували якісь невеликі кошти
на організацію фестивалю «Битва за море».
І більшу частину грошей нам давали підприємці.
Тобто у нас не було грошей,
які б нам давала влада чи гранти.
Але ми писали, ми їздили на тренінги,
2019-го ми подали декілька заявок.
І дві з них реалізувалися.
Це проєкт молодіжного центру
і «Будуємо Україну разом».
У 2014-му році, коли на сході почалася війна
і дуже багато сімей просто втратили своє майно.
І вийшло, що два друга, з Краматорська і зі Львова,
вони вирішили допомогти один одному.
Той запросив, сказав:
«От, подивись, що у нас тут відбувається».
А друг зі Львова сказав: «А я приїду зі своїми друзями
і відремонтую тобі будівлю».
І з 2014-го року, здається, це почалося
як такий вже сталий процес.
І цей процес став таким популярним.
І БУР почали запрошувати до себе в регіони
не тільки на сході, але і по всій Україні.
І так сталося, що ми планували з БУРом
робити саме це приміщення і ремонт в ньому.
Але коронавірус змістив плани
і БУР допомагає нам робити другу чергу.
Це двір наш, це такий Public space,
у якому можна буде зібратися.
Ми трошки поїздили по Україні,
понавчалися.
І зрозуміли, що всі вже пішли вперед.
Тому що вони створюють такі простори.
І ми подумали, чому б нам
таке місце не знайти.
Ми звернулися до місцевої влади,
почали пошук комунального майна.
Але зрештою не отримали взагалі нічого.
Згодом ми знайшли класних підприємців.
Які кажуть: «Ну, знаєте, хлопці, можливо,
це не найкраще місце у Скадовську».
Але тут точно є щось цікаве.
Ця будівля — вона, фактично,
ровесник нашого маяка, який є на острові.
Ми взяли цей маяк і просто перетворили на Light house —
будинок, який світить, який є прожектором.
«Дивіться, друзі, ми тут всі, їдьте до нас, давайте!»
Саме цей маяк надихає, дає розуміння,
що це не просто якесь сучасне  приміщення.
Не просто воно зараз з'явилося,
а воно має якийсь історичний бекграунд.
Ми хочемо зробити це модним, зробити
такий молодіжний формат розумної молоді,
яка сама отримує навички,
шукає можливості.
Ми хочемо зробити це модним
на місцевому і регіональному рівні.
Ідея муралу з'явилася дуже давно.
І в якийсь момент ми зрозуміли,
що самі ми той мурал не намалюємо.
І коли ми запросили вже команду БУРу,
Андрій, їхній спеціаліст-мураліст,
який побачив це місце, намалював саме таку картинку.
Крім молодіжного центру,
ми допомагаємо ще двом сім'ям.
Це сім'я Олександра і сім'я Ніни,
яка опікується будинком сімейного типу.
Саша — АТОвець, який служив на сході.
Потрапили під обстріл і десь вночі
на позиції його поранив снайпер.
Поранення було в голову.
Йому лікарі давали 1 %.
Привіт! Як у вас тут справи?
Та, як завжди, класно. Привіт, хлопці!
Саша отримав компенсацію, чи допомогу
від держави на те, щоб купити собі власний будинок.
Він цього хотів сам —
жити окремо від свого діда.
Ми познайомилися з його дідом
і зрозуміли, що це точно історія для БУРу.
І що ви думаєте, коли дах будуть ложити, сьогодні?
Ні, сьогодні ні, треба її
підшити спершу, а потім затягнути.
Саша придбав цей будинок разом з дідом.
Вони вибирали, вони вибрали
місце так, щоб не далеко в селі.
Він був не далеко від його діда.
Саша, привіт! Добрий день!
Як справи? Нормально.
Ми тут до вас на вогник зайшли.
Ну що ти, Саша, хату бачив?
Так? Розваляли, побудували.
Нічого, все буде класно там.
У нас Семен навіть прийшов,
цей ваш художник Ульянівський.
Він казав, що щось тобі намалює на хаті,
він ж Дімі намалював цей танк.
То він тобі якогось корабля намалює,
чи що, ну сам вже скажеш, що захочеш.
Коли вони купили будинок,
він їм дуже сподобався.
До моменту, поки вони
не почали віддирати шпалери.
Тому що там виявилося,
як по класиці, дуже все погано.
І стін не було.
І наразі вже зроблено дуже багато.
Повністю розібрана прибудова,
викладена нова кладка там цегляна.
І так само йдуть внутрішні
відновлювальні роботи.
Так само і в сім'ях, ми коли приїжджаємо,
то бачимо, що там велика частина роботи вже зроблена.
Та, яку ми би не зробили за такий короткий час.
Тому що є ментори, є будівельники, які закріплені за цими
групами, і вони знають точно, що робити цим людям.
БУР — це гуманітарний процес, як мінімум.
Тому що ті будинки, які він будує — це 10 %
від тієї користі, яку він приносить громаді загалом.
БУР-табір, його місія залучити не тільки волонтерів
з усієї України, а ще й місцеве населення.
І важливо донести людям цю ідею.
І вже коли приїжджає БУР-табір —
якась частина волонтерів займається тим,
що вони роблять промоцію
у так званому БУР-мобілі.
Такий причіп, який класно обладнаний,
класно розмальований.
І там готують бутерброди,
там є навіть якийсь інструмент,
який можна взяти і ним попрацювати.
Але він більш створений для промоції.
Ми ставимо його в центрі міста,
люди приходять і цікавляться.
«А що це таке, що це за формат?
Куди піти, чим допомогти?»
Багато місцевих, в принципі, приходить.
Невелика кількість залишається,
але людям цікаво подивитися на те, як це працює.
Родина, якій ми допомагаємо.
Це Олександр, це колишній воїн АТО.
Він був поранений у голову
і зараз проходить реабілітацію.
До роботи можуть долучитися місцеві спокійно.
І це одна така головна мета, бо місцеві не так сильно
розуміють цей волонтерський напрям.
Взагалі, в Україні, хоч це і такий тренд,
але багато хто ще не розуміє,
нащо робити щось безплатно.
І БУР-мобіль, і інформаційні кампанії
в інтернеті, які ми проводимо, —
вони спрямовані на те, щоб охопити
максимальну кількість місцевих.
Показати їм, що буде, коли БУР поїде.
Можливо, ми і самі можемо організуватися
та поїхати собі допомогти якійсь людині.
З її проблемами.
Або зробити якийсь місцевий простір
занедбаний кращим, ніж він є.
Також приділити для цього уваги
небагато і небагато сил.
БУР-табір поділяється на дві групи.
То перша група — це перший тиждень,
друга група — другий тиждень.
Табір класичний, тобто люди
проживають або в палатках,
або, як у нас, проживають
у спортивному училищі.
В гуртожитку є просто класні умови для них.
І вони зранку їдуть по сім'ях або в молодіжний центр,
займаються виключно будівельними роботами.
О третій годині дня вони всі
з'їжджаються у свої місця дислокації.
Можна сказати, до табору безпосередньо.
Там вечеряють, дають собі лад, йдуть в душ.
І ввечері у них культурна програма.
♪ Лиш одній в цілім світі,
розкажу про любов. ♪
♪ Душа страждає,
звук трембіти лунає, ♪
♪ а що серце кохає,
бо гаряче мов жар. ♪
В останній день ми збираємося, палимо ватру.
І розказуємо про те, взагалі,
які відчуття, ділимося емоціями.
Тобто на другий тиждень вже приїжджають нові люди.
І так само проходить той ж процес.
Але головне, що вони
не тільки допомагають нам,
а й самі знайомляться,
отримують якусь користь з цього.
Вивчають Україну, знайомляться з Україною.
Тут нас дуже тепло прийняли,
всі знають, що ми їмо в Андрія.
І пані Анжела нам готує.
Пан Андрій — це дуже крутий дядько
і дуже смачно у нього готують. Дуже дякуємо!
Я не знаю, як я додому поїду,
буду викочуватися зі Скадовська,
тому що настільки смачно.
Скажіть, будь ласка, навіщо ви це робите?
Ну, по-перше, я люблю і сам смачно поїсти
й знаю, як сильно це важливо, особливо
коли ти молодий і потребуєш енергії.
Тим більше коли ви займаєтесь
такою важкою фізичною працею.
Взагалі, якщо ви помітили, місто Скадовськ
трохи відірване від всіх центрів України.
Найближче місто, більш-менш, за 100 кілометрів.
І ми тут відчуваємо, ніби до нас приїхала Україна.
Це трошки інша Україна,
і ви нагадуєте нам, якою вона може бути.
Красивою, енергійною, вмотивованою.
Я надзвичайно зворушений,
що ви тут працювали і зробили так багато.
І трішечки цією роботою повертаєте нам себе.
Такі куточки, як Скадовськ, не дуже
популярні, і їх мало знає молодь.
І їм цікаво знайти тут щось нове для себе.
Отримати якийсь новий
досвід, нові знання.
Отже, всім привіт,
ви у нас волонтери другої зміни.
Це у нас вже другий тиждень
табору в Скадовську.
Ми раді вас вітати, почнімо
трошки дізнаватись одне одного.
Почнімо з простого:
говоріть, як вас звати, звідки ви.
І чому вам зараз важливо бути тут,
у цей момент в Скадовську,
на таборі в «Будуємо Україну разом».
Мене звати Макс, мені 16 років, я з міста Харків.
Я тут, тому що хочу дізнатися,
чим займається молодь з інших міст України.
Всім привіт, мене звати Маша,
ми в Переяславі також розвиваємо толокою
такий самий молодіжний простір,
як Артем і його команда розвивають тут, в місті.
З БУРом я познайомилась
рік тому, коли БУР приїхав до нас.
У наш молодіжний простір.
І також я побачила,
що багато волонтерів з всієї України
приїхало навіть у власну відпустку,
щоб допомогти нам.
Покращити те, чим ми займалися.
Привіт усім, мене звати Катя,
ми з чоловіком приїхали з Чикаго.
Ми цього літа будемо в Україні три місяці,
у нас така довга відпустка між магістеркою,
і поки ми почнемо працювати восени.
Ми приїхали сюди,
тому що я є частиною української діаспори.
І виростала з дуже сильним
і глибоким українським корінням.
Було дуже цікаво справді зануритися
в сучасну українську культуру.
Щось зробити, де ми б могли дуже
з молодими українцями спілкуватися.
Познайомитися, зрозуміти
трошки більше про ваш світогляд.
З вами поділитися,
яка у нас є українська культура.
Привіт, я Жоаов, з Бразилії,
знаю, що не всі можуть розуміти, що я говорю,
але я буду пробувати трошки.
Я дуже хотів бути тут, в Україні,
і дізнатися більше про країну і про її мешканців.
І я подумав, БУР буде цікавим місцем для того,
щоб дізнатися людей, дізнатися про Україну.
І також, звичайно,
допомогти будувати Україну разом.
Якщо ми кажемо, що у нас в Україні є якісь зміни,
то, по великому рахунку, вони відбуваються з тим,
як покоління за поколінням підростає.
І в них зростає планка, і вони для себе
шукають якість можливості, якісь нові ідеї,
якісь нові сенси взагалі цього буття в Україні.
Ми так само долучаємося до цього процесу тим,
що робимо маленькі такі проєкти,
які інколи просто репутаційні для міста.
А інколи вони розкривають місто по-новому.
Тобто показують,
що Скадовськ — це сучасно,
Скадовськ — це цікаво,
Скадовськ так само може бути містом,
куди я повернуся після того,
як отримаю гарну освіту.
Я впевнений, що багато хто ще
буде переварювати ту інформацію.
Буде розуміти, що ого, у нас був БУР, а що таке.
Вони тільки познайомляться з цим муралом,
вони — люди, які, як тільки закінчиться сезон,
тільки зрозуміють, що у них щось відбулося.
Ті підприємці, які долучилися до цього процесу,
вони зрозуміють, що так,
ми можемо робити разом реальні речі.
Добро завжди повертається до тебе.
Це такі якісь фундаментальні речі,
які відбуваються з кожною людиною.
І ми всі знаємо, що зроблене
один раз добро — повернеться тобі.
Тому що тобі на шляху
зустрінеться така сама людина.
Але такий практичний варіант цієї допомоги,
він лише в тому, що ми розвиваємо один одного.
Розвиваємося як суспільство, ми стаємо
складнішими, більш зрозумілими собі.
І, знову ж, ми вирощуємо той потенціал
для майбутніх поколінь, для самих себе.
І ті можливості, які з цим з'являються,
просто допомагають нам вижити і реалізуватися.